good morning vision my name is Evan
Carmichael buy one word and believe and
I believe that entrepreneurs will solve
all of the world's major problems so I
hope you on your journey
today's message is persevere over to you
each job a lot of people come to me they
say oh I want to be an entrepreneur and
I go that's great what's your idea and
they go well I don't have one yet and I
say well I think you should go get a job
as a busboy or something till you find
something you're really passionate about
because it's a lot of work and I'm
convinced that about half of what
separates the successful entrepreneurs
from the non successful ones is pure
perseverance it is so hard you pour so
much your life into this thing there are
such rough moments in time that most
people give up I don't blame them it's
really tough and it consumes your life I
mean if you're if you've got a family
and you're in the early days of a
company it's I can't imagine how one
could do it I'm sure it's been done but
it's rough because it's a pretty much
you know an 18-hour day job seven days a
week for a while so unless you have a
lot of passion about this you're going
to not survive you're going to give it
up so you got to have an idea of or a
problem or a wrong that you want to
write that you're passionate about
otherwise you're not going to have the
perseverance to stick it through and I
think that's half the battle right there
I often get what are the most common
rules of success about all these people
my channels we've done so many top-10
fulfiled amenities of belief live in the
west context what are the consistent
themes that come back over and over and
over and over
again here they are the three main ones
octo earth to plow it again to do is a
passion boat right they haven't created
either they want to do that they love
but their attacks do that they need to
see creating the world second did the
gun start it did something fun did it
just down there at the end they just
hope the one we help them can happen you
did you tell themself that when this
thing happens dinners and it start
no they start yeah when I eat it you do
something about it because you way then
that's waiting turns into weeks and
months and years and eventually like
anima box and as when tires that the
song dies within you you gotta start and
three is it persevere to get cold
when it got hot they kept open and this
is why it's so important you love what
we do because you have to be a little
bit crazy you have to do it even when
you're not seeing results you have to do
with people and you have setbacks and
family is out in front of you you have
to persevere if you look at every single
successful person that it is unfair
person if you look out you but then
we're at the top of their game they
persevered through a lot of crap to get
there it's not since this overnight
sensation that takes off and does well
and if you are lucky enough to house
that happens it puts the business out
because you don't hurt a few accrues you
have to do the work and this is part of
why I started money because part of why
I started doing what I do because when I
had my first business I expected it to
be harder but not as hard as well you
know it was reading magazine articles
and web pages and really all successful
ways made me feel like you know I think
to do it I can do it too I got something
me I can make this a business and I want
to prepare to how crushing it was it was
it was the most soul-crushing part of my
eyelid
I started my business and couldn't work
and work and work and work and just not
getting any kind of resolved not getting
any kind of customers not getting any
kind of every maybe even 2000 month
even the same chains of beans every
single day for lunch
celebrating the victory with McDonald's
french fries like decide and to do that
every single day you can do it for so
long before take this massive Poland in
the same I learned more than this and
it's the love for what you're doing to
get you through and I saw this
department would take a lot of entrence
think about putting on a regular basis I
think witnessing back the next day and
continues to work but we don't talk
about a done we read the article Racine
is also success stories people taking
off and they only see work hard but you
don't feel the struggles and failures
that are part of their past it was part
of why I do what I do I wanted to share
with the world share with the guys to
give you motivation to give you mo
belief that you can do it that even
though it's tough you're going to think
it's kind of problem at least to me I
found that my models except by looking
at people who big do what I want to go
through right and achieve massive
success none of the things that I aspire
to do in my own way that's helpful and
just remembering that a lot of these
people who look up to they started with
less than what you already have her neck
they had like a gift which you have they
took action which hopefully you're doing
but they probably had less resources
than you already have
right blessed is your sports more less
connection less opportunities with what
we have is Dmytro technology now then
what were you have right hand they had
less than what you already have and so
the difference is they stuck with it be
persevered
they push through push through when they
felt like giving up ladies and so
feeling like you want to quit can be
normal because
hard to do this beam entrepreneur but
you have to persevere through it have a
good idea to get started but don't
persevere we then constantly start
without second thoughts stop never build
anything - you need me to curse
so the first main ideas I'm curious one
of the biggest thing that you have to
persevere through in your business what
was the biggest challenge that you faced
or are currently facing then you have a
really hard time work that you have gold
deeper in and really persevere through
let me know share down comes below I'm
reading your content I also want to give
a quick share September leaks thank you
so much for always forward if you're
picking up 10 copies of my book your one
word and you're posting it on YouTube
channel that also review thank you thank
you thank you so much I'm really happy
to do it so thank you guys so much for
watching I believe in you so continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love and I'll see you
get more more a for another shot of
espresso
[Music]
oh I'm not going to say to you tonight
Hamilton but I know we like as teenagers
I get for writing an essay right and we
have trouble double-knotted you want to
give up did you ever feel like that all
the time all the time and then you push
through it like you push through it
because what's the alternative you're
going to leave that idea stuck in your
head forever
that sucks the alternative is you go
through life and you had this great idea
and nothing came of it because you got
tired and yeah sometimes you don't go to
the party that all your friends are at
because the idea is calling to you in
that moment
wait for it's a great example of that I
was on my way to my friend's birthday
party when that lyric showed up when
death doesn't discriminate showed up in
my head idea came on the a down I
started writing it down in the train and
I can eat that of the a train Prague
dancers are dancing I have my headphones
on I get out I the whole chorus comes
all at once I write it down and I
suddenly see the shape of the whole song
I was just like intercourse Eber that's
who he is
I go into my friend's party I go hey
what's up man I've never stayed I gotta
go
I get on the L train and I write the
rest of the song on the way back home
from the L to the a backup to 207 Street
you have to do that sometimes you have
to say no to your friends to say yes to
your work because what are going to do
like lose that idea because you decided
like have a drink with your friends like
not worth it
your friend will be there when I look
back at all my business accomplishments
CNN was the most exciting and most most
challenging and the most satisfying one
when we were successful because you know
I got proven right I was Time Magazine's
a person of the year for the whole world
I mean that's you know what more could
you do than that I made the cover
success magazine I held a copy up today
I said dad is that enough I'm on the
cover of Success Magazine you know
so long you know and then then we had
the AOL merger so it didn't last very
long and I was dining out again one of
the worst mistakes that's ever been made
in business we went into it half-cocked
and unprepared and not that's something
you don't want to do on a merger of that
consequence you know you want to really
be careful when you're dealing with
billions and billions of dollars and the
careers of literally thousands of people
that were you know their life savings
was wiped out too I had some doubts and
I voiced them and I talked to the best
people I could for advice and they felt
like it there there was no way I could
have stopped it so I went along with it
be a good soldier and and I lost 80% of
my money I lost my job at CNN and Turner
Broadcasting at that same time Jane
Fonda and I got a divorce and I lost the
grandchild that passed away and so I was
really down and I had two choices one
you either go down I wish I had plenty
of excuses for but I didn't want to go
down I I still felt like I had
contributions to make and I just gritted
my teeth and said I'm going to come out
of this there's no like Scarlett O'Hara
I did at the end of the first half of
gamma the women member shoot so standing
up on the hill as the camera went back
and she says as God is my witness I'll
never be hungry again you know at such
as God is my witness I'm going to get
through this and and I'm going to make a
comeback